la dernière fois on a introduit la
notion d'apprentissage superviser
rapidement en gros l'apprentissage
superviser consiste à analyser un jeu de
données qui consiste à un ensemble de
perrefitte chose les boys ou
reconstruire une fonction de prédiction
c'est à dire une fonction qui calcule
délai bol y pour des figures os x alors
présenté comme ça ça peut donner
l'impression de quelque chose de très
machine learning by jiss on entre tout
ça sauf qu'en fait l'apprentissage
superviser date de moins de 250 ans à
l'époque où les premiers chercheurs en
intelligence artificielle et en machine
learning inventaire la régression
linéaire
en ce sens le premier chercheur en il ya
de l'histoire pourrait être un certain
roger joseph bosco vic autour de 1755
pour interpréter des mesures
géographique les détails importe peu
toujours est il que parce que richie
s'est retrouvé avec une dimension du
free jazz une dimension de l'ibs et
plein de points dans cet espace
sauf que boscovich savait que les les
buzz de ces données étaient des mesures
empirique et était donc nécessairement
imprécises et postulats alors que ces
mesures étaient erronées il chercha à
décrire les données comme devant être
sur une droite avec des erreurs de
mesures verticales qui éloigne les
données de la droite à la fin du xviiie
siècle
le géant pierre simon laplace
formalisera les intuitions géométrique
de boscovich définissant ainsi la
méthode moindre déviation absolue ou
liste absolute déviation pour trouver
une régularité dans les données de façon
cruciale comme klm dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode précédent
l'algorithme de machine learning de buzz
kovic la place permet d'exploiter la
droite calculé pour effectuer des
prédictions pour les features encore non
observé si je récapitule l'algorithme de
boscovich la place est incroyablement
simple on a un nuage de points il suffit
de trouver une droite qu'il colle assez
bien à ce nuage de points et on utilise
ensuite cette droite pour effectuer des
prédictions nous parle alors de
régression linéaire puisque on ramène la
complexité d'un nuage de points à la
simplicité d'une droite
or une droite en fait c'est un ensemble
de deux paramètres décrivent d'un côté
l'inclinaison de la droite que l'on
appelle sa pente et de l'autre côté sa
hauteur que l'on appelle sont ordonnés à
l'origine oui ce sont les a et b de
l'équation y est égal à ax suspect ainsi
la régression linéaire c'est résumer
tout un jeu de données à seulement deux
nombres pas mal alors dit comme ça avec
un séminaire ça paraît simple et
pourtant déjà avec ce cas simpliste ce
n'est pas si simple
au début des années 1800 legendre ygos
proposèrent une approche alternative
pour calculer une bonne droite qui
traverse un nuage de points ils
montrèrent que leur approche était
optimale si l'on cherche à minimiser la
somme des carrés des erreurs et c'est
pour ça que l'algorithme de legendre
gosse est aujourd'hui davantage connue
sous le nom de méthode des moindres
carrés mais du coup on a deux façons
différentes de tracer une droite à
travers un nuage de points d'un côté il
ya les moindre déviation de boscovich la
place et de l'autre n'a les moindres
carrés de legendre gosse laquelle des
deux approches la meilleure est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux minimiser la somme des
erreurs ou la somme des carrés des
erreurs j'aime bien cette question parce
qu'elle en fait incroyablement profonde
il y aurait tellement de choses à dire
ce sujet mais comme j'ai déjà beaucoup
de choses à vous dire aujourd'hui je
vais laisser cette question en suspens
et je vais vous l'essayez réfléchir
sachant que personnellement je pense que
la bonne réponse à izel toujours est il
qu'aujourd'hui à l'école ou à
l'université
on enseigne qu'une seule de ces deux
méthodes à savoir la méthode des
moindres carrés de l'eau gendre gosse et
on a tendance à complètement ignoré les
moindre déviation de boscovich la place
et tout ça de façon amusante surtout à
cause de la place et son théorème
centrale limite
bon je vais laisser ça de côté en fait
aujourd'hui la quasi totalité de la
communauté scientifique utilise la
méthode des moindres carrés de le
joindre gosse pour déterminer des
relations entre des variables comme pv
légal nrt ou disons la manière dont
l'ancienneté et la productivité d'un
youtuber scientifique affecté son nombre
d'abonnés
les moindres carrés de legendre gosses
sont particulièrement utilisés pour
calculer la corrélation entre des
features aider les boys de façon
grossière
la corrélation mesure à quel point la
régression linéaire colo donner cette
corrélation est plus un
quand la régression linéaire monde et
contient les données elle est égale à -1
quand elle descend et contient les
données et elle est proche de zéro si la
droite ne passe pas franchement par les
données et d'ailleurs ça ça montre les
limites du concept de corrélation vous
connaissez sans doute le dicton qui dit
que corrélation n'implique pas causalité
si ce n'est pas le cas je vous
recommande vivement cette vidéo de la
statistique explique et amoucha mais
indique t on au moins connu est celui
qui dit que causalité n'implique pas
corrélation par exemple imaginons le
label y est égale à e puissance x alors
y est clairement causé par x puisque on
l'obtient vient à calcul déterministe
mais pour x entre 0 et 100 la
corrélation est inférieure à 30%
et je ne parle pas du chaos x implique y
de façon non monotone bref la
corrélation a beaucoup de limites et on
le fait souvent dire des choses qu'il ne
dit pas ce qu'elle mesure vraiment c'est
la performance de la régression linéaire
pour décrire un nuage de points et c'est
déjà pas si mal
ça permet de donner une idée d'à quel
point on peut faire confiance à la
régression linéaire pour prédire des
labels étant donné des piqûres en effet
il ya une autre façon intéressante est
souvent utilisée d'interpréter la
corrélation plus tôt le carré de la
corrélation errecart est aussi appelée
coefficient de détermination en effet
regardons les erreurs de la régression
linéaire et comparons les aux variations
des les bowls indépendamment de tout
lien avec les phishers on peut montrer
que les erreurs de la règle et soul in
her sont toujours moins grande que les
variations des les boys ça revient à
dire qu'avec la régression linéaire on a
diminué notre incertitudes quant aux
valeurs des levels et bien vers carey
est essentiellement cela il s'agit de 1
- le rapport des erreurs moyenne par les
variations des levels ce que l'on
interprète souvent comme étant la
proportion de la variance des levels que
l'on parvient à expliquer à l'aide de la
régression linéaire
en gros quand air carré est égal à 1
alors la régression linéaire explique
entièrement le lien entre les futurs
hôtels et les bosses mais si air car est
à peu près égale 1 0 alors la récréation
linéaire
apporte rien ainsi air carré est un bon
indicateur de la validité de la
régression linéaire alors jusque là je
n'ai parlé que de droite et ça c'est
parce que l'espace des phisheurs ce que
j'ai considéré était de dimension 1
mais contrairement à cannes aime
d'ailleurs la régression linéaire se
généralise en fait très bien aux
dimensions supérieures ainsi l'espace
des phisheurs et de dimensions 2 c'est à
dire si on cherche à prédire le label y
à partir de deux fincher x1 et x2 alors
on pourra représenter les données par
des points dans un espace de dimension 3
et la régression linéaire consiste à
trouver le plan qui colle le mieux au
nuage de points de cet espace plus
généralement si l'espace des phisheurs
et de dimensions d alors la régression
linéaire sera le calcul d'un hyper plan
de dimension des à l'intérieur d'un
espace de dimension des plus sains ou là
des puces 1e dimensions et celle des
levels
alors ça peut faire peur dit comme ça ni
père plan dimension d mais de la même
manière qu'on peut représenter une
droite part de nombre on peut
représenter un plan par trois nombres et
un hyper plan de dimension des parts des
puces un nombre d'un point de vue
calculatoire la régression linéaire pour
un espèce de features des dimensions des
correspond simplement a résumé tout un
jeu de données par le calcul de des
puces un nombre et le truc génial c'est
que le jeu entre gosses nous ont décrit
un algorithme c'est à dire qu'ils ont
décrit les étapes de calcul nécessaire
pour calculer ces des puces un nombre
bref la régression linéaire
c'est un outil de calcul puissant qui
est très utilisée aujourd'hui
et là vous allez me dire mais du coup
pourquoi est ce qu'on a besoin de
réseaux de neurones et bien le problème
de la régression linéaire c'est qu'elle
ne décris que des relations
lumière sauf que beaucoup de relations
entre fishers et les boys ne sont pas
linéaires
à commencer par le cas où les levels ne
sont pas des nombres mais par exemple
des like dislike ou par exemple des
spams pas spam ou par exemple pour faire
de la reconnaissance d'objets à ce
moment là pour quand même exploiter les
structures linéaire qui ont le bon goût
d'être simple à conceptualiser et à
calculer
on peut chercher à essayer de coller un
peu à la régression linéaire par exemple
au lieu de considérer juste été like
dislike on peut créer artificiellement
des échelles plus ou moins like this
light malheureusement les données seront
toujours tout en haut où tout en bas de
cette échelle et du coup faire passer
une droite par ce nuage de points
ça risque fort de ne pas franchement le
faire mais ce que l'on peut faire c'est
une presque droite ou plus exactement on
va calculer un point de rupture et
broder autour de ce point de rupture
soit à l'aide d'une jolie courbe en s
soit l'aide de morceaux de droite
prenons le cas où l'espace défi job est
de dimension 2 pour mieux visualiser ce
point de rupture
dans ce cas le point de rupture ne sera
pas un point mais une droite la couture
se fera alors dans la direction
perpendiculaire à la droite et pour des
features de dimension des le point de
rupture sera maintenant un hyper plan de
dimension des moyens avec là encore une
couture dans la direction
perpendiculaire ce qu'on a construit là
ce sont des classiques year linéaire
alors en fonction de la couture utilisé
pour coller les différents bout du tice
différents noms pour la jolie couture en
forme de s on parle de régression
logistique et dans le cas des morceaux
de droite on parle de svm pour se
portent vector machine mais le détail
importe peu ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que un peu comme pour la
régression linéaire déclassifier or
linéaire pour un espace des features de
dimension des peuvent être décrits par
des non pas mieux encore il existe des
algorithmes efficace à qui vous pouvez
donner tout un jeu de données et qui
calculeront automatiquement et
rapidement les des nombres de la
classification linéaire et de nos jours
ces classifications linéaires sont très
utilisés qui vit quand l'une des
premières très gros application de la
classification l'ine
était la classification des emails en
spam pas spam mais ces classifications
linéaires ont aussi leurs limites et je
vais finir avec une petite image à
l'écran ça c'est ce que l'on appelle le
ou exclusifs ou xor et pendant longtemps
c'était l'argument conclusive contre les
méthodes lean et y compris la
classification linéaire ou pas je vous
laisse y réfléchir
la dernière fois on a parlé de notre
premier algorithmes de machine learning
qui a été calme et ça me semble encore
eric au fait remarquer qui en fait des
hypothèses que j'ai oublié d'expliciter
pour que le théorème de cover ehrhart
s'applique en particulier faut que la
loi de probabilité des données soit une
combinaison de d'irak et de distribution
absolument continue par rapport à la
métrique de l'espace en particulier il
faut que seul m finissent par être
vérifiée à savoir que si vous avez une
donnée qui est tirée selon la loi de
probabilité
alors avec probabilité 1 en tirant d'eau
plein d'autres données vous finirez par
avoir une suite de données qui vont se
rapprocher de la donne et que vous aviez
tiré initialement prono giraud sauveur
se demande s'il n'est pas possible
d'améliorer la complexité en temps de
l'algorithme canet ce qui est possible
de faire une prédiction finalement très
rapide on entend qu'il ne dépend pas
énormément de la taille des données
collectées
c'est une question très intéressant
d'ailleurs je me la suis posée en
préparant notamment la vidéo de la
semaine dernière il se trouve que si la
dimension des featurettes égal à 1 ou à
deux la réponse est oui on est capable
d'avoir des algues au rythme très rapide
pour faire la prédiction de cayenne
malheureusement en dimensions
supérieures il semble que la réponse
soit non ma connaissance encore une
question ouverte mais d'après ce poste
de sur stock exchange il semblerait que
résoudre ce problème en transe ou
linéaires correspondrait à résoudre le
problème de satisfaits habilité en temps
inférieur à deux puissances n
aujourd'hui à la plupart des pharmaciens
pense que c'est pas possible
bref on n'a pas prouvé que c'était
impossible de voir un algorithme
vacances ou linéaires pour appliquer
caennais non mais j'ai envie de dire que
a priori les réponses viennent parce que
si vous arrivez à prouver que la réponse
est oui pour toutes dimensions alors je
pense qu'un prix turing vous attend du
prix turing pour ceux qui connaissent
pas c'est l'équivalent du prix nobel
pour l'informatique
un vidéo précédentes on avait vu que le
gros problème de knn était le fait que
les complexités d'échantillonnage de
cannes n était très très grande en fait
la complexité échantillonnage semble
grandir de façon exponentielle avec la
dimension de ça c'est très mauvais comme
l'expliquent sauf ça aux âges et
emmanuel jacob
c'est ce que l'on appelle la malédiction
de la vie
mention ou encore le fléau de la
dimension c'est le fait que les espaces
de grandes dimensions se comporte pas
forcément comme les espaces de
dimensions plus petites que l'on connaît
bien pour ça qu'il faut faire vraiment
très gaffe machine learning a souvent
des idées qu'on peut avoir
qui marchent en petites dimensions mais
il faut absolument voir comment ça
marche quand la dimension de l'espace
grandi et en particulier si la
complexité du problème grandi de façon
exponentielle
c'est pas bon alors amis de deux riches
se demande du coup s'il n'est pas
possible de réduire à la main des
dimensions de l'espace en enlevant
certaines dimensions peu pertinentes
comme ça à la main c'est vraiment pas
facile et a priori en devançant général
si vous écartez comme ça des dimensions
bas après vous perdez de l'information
est possible que l'information utile
pour effectuer les prédictions
disparaissent lorsqu on aurait des
dimensions hanoi a fait alors remarquer
qu'il ya une méthode qui s'appelle
l'analyse par composante principale
principales composantes analysis en
anglais on appelle cipi sièges il ya
aussi une variante d'officiels qui
s'appelle single of value 10 composition
ou svd en gros l'idée de ces approches
c2c d'enlever les dimensions qui
semblent pas pertinentes de façon
automatique de détecter automatiquement
les dimensions dans lequel on fait un
peu de variation des données pour
essayer d'orienter l'espace pour
regarder uniquement les dimensions sur
lesquels il ya une forte variation dans
les données alors en effet ces méthodes
sont vraiment génial marche rentrée très
bien mais elles ont aussi leurs limites
et on en reparlera dans des prochaines
vidéos
je vous ai compris se demandant s'il
serait pas possible de choisir un petit
peu plus à la main de choisir quels sont
les features qu'ils ont faites sont
pertinents à la prédiction et ça pendant
longtemps c'était ce qui était fait en
machine learning
mais aujourd'hui le paradigme notamment
du diplôme ning cessé de faire en sorte
que toute la sélection tout tout ce
travail en fait ce prêt mâchage des
données finalement soit au entièrement
automatisés et qu'il n'est pas besoin
d'une intervention humaine pour pouvoir
ensuite faire des prédictions en
particulier du coup aujourd'hui le
machine learning notamment le diplôme ou
qui cherchent à voir directement des
données brutes
analyser ce machine en ingla sera obligé
d'avoir des espaces de très très grande
dimension et tous ces espaces de grandes
dimensions ça fait forcément appel à de
la gemme linéaire donc atomix se demande
si pour apprendre par exemple le diplôme
ning c'est vraiment nécessaire de
maîtriser ces notions deuxième lumière
la réponse est vraiment oui
malheureusement
l'aja binaire est vraiment vraiment
centrale aux techniques de machine
learning d'aujourd'hui tout comme
certaines notions de base de l'analyse
et de la théorie des probabilités
donc ça fait évidemment beaucoup de
choses à apprendre pour la dja binaire
en particulier fait une série de vidéos
sur when did a et je recommande aussi
très vivement la série de vidéos de
football bat pour l'analyse aussi j'ai
fait quelques vidéos sur you wanted à
effet brandon a aussi une excellente
série sur l'analyse souvent c'est sont
pas forcément des vidéos qui sont ultra
scolaire donc c'est très utile d'avoir
un manuel scolaire pour pouvoir vraiment
apprendre ces choses je pense aussi que
ces vidéos aideront beaucoup à avoir une
intuition de vraiment ce qui se passe
dans ces espaces aux dimensions de
trélon dimensions ou dans ses calculs
infinitésimaux bref de façon peut-être à
signer attendue du match de prépa sont
en fait souvent très très très utile
pour pouvoir faire notamment des
machines à cormont 79 lâché un petit
spoiler apparemment un trigone peppers
parle pas de pentagone je crois je vais
pas aller le voir du coup par coup qu'il
lixon du dos qui est sorti sur nes de
sciences où il parle de pentagone et la
vidéo est plutôt cool
romain miller et mon compte le tubulaire
remarquer que nous code génétique
dépendent aussi de notre environnement
et se demande du coup ci ça remet pas en
cause la faible complexité de solomonoff
du cerveau enfant en fait j'ai envie de
dire que d'une certaine manière la
modification du code génétique par des
méthodes de des pigeons tic notamment
c'est en fait un apprentissage de
l'environnement c'est une façon dont
l'environnement influence le code
génétique et donc la structure du
cerveau de l'enfant
donc là encore ça correspond d'une
certaine manière a volé de la complicité
de solomonoff utile de l'environnement
pour pouvoir améliorer l'intelligence du
cerveau d'équipement 55 se demande si du
coup si on regarde toute l'évolution de
l'espèce humaine vu qu'à l'origine il ya
sans doute une bataille très simple avec
une boîte génétique très très simple
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas dire
finalement que la complicité de
seulement 9,2
m en fait se réduit à cette complexité
très simple initiale et raconter non
parce qu'en fait dans ce processus de
sélection au cours de l'évolution
il ya eu beaucoup d'influencé de
l'environnement et du cumul certaines
aires beaucoup de machine learning sur
les codes génétiques et des espèces
vivantes qui a eu lieu
et d'ailleurs ce processus de sélection
naturelle c'est quelque chose qui avait
été proposé par turing dans son papier
de 1950 pour pouvoir sélectionner les
meilleurs learning machine initiale
c'est à dire les meilleurs cerveaux
enfants plus généralement les parallèles
entre l'informatique théorique et la
biologie en fait sont très très très
nombreux et d'ailleurs j'en avais parlé
à tlx à clé et la vidéo 2 x anglais est
sorti récemment moule concédé le voir
c'est sur les algorithmes du vivant et
notamment sa parle des grandes idées
d'alan turing de john von neumann et de
solomonoff qui ont des conséquences
majeures sur la biologie
enfin je vais finir avec un petit bémol
par rapport à mes explications de dar ya
un argument que j'ai sauté et qui est
très important puisque je suis tombé en
fait dans le sophisme cas swing et
tearing qui le fait que juste parce que
machine est compréhensible théoriquement
ne veut pas dire qu'elle peut être
compressible de façon pratique en
particulièrement si on pense à
intelligence artificielle alpha 0 alpha
06 une intelligence artificielle qui a
battu toutes les autres intelligence
artificielle aux échecs au jeu de go un
autre jeux du même genre
cette année ces évidences artificielle
elle n'a pas utilisé de machine learning
en français l'a pas utilisé des données
qui venaient de l'extérieur est juste
parti de quelques règles simplistes que
ces différents jeux et elle a ensuite
fait beaucoup de calculs donc c'est une
dernière c'est une intelligence
artificielle sans machine ne renie en
tout cas sans apprentissage des données
qui viendrait du monde extérieur et on a
envie de dire que après tout ces calculs
toutes ces simulations de plusieurs
millions de parties de jeux de go et
d'échecs et d'autre on a envie de dire
que alpha 0 a gagné en complexité pour
en fait elle n'a pas gagné en complexité
de solomonoff puisque son état futur
peut-être essentiellement prédit de son
état initial donc activement la
complexité sur le monop d'alpha 0 après
toutes ces procédures de simulation et
de parti est en fait pas plus grande que
sa combi sida selon l'ofs initial ça
techniquement c'est vrai sauf que pour
passer de l'état initial à l'état où
elle est aujourd'hui
en fait le temps de calcul est
absolument énorme et du coup en
particulier en pratique si on veut une
machine qui joue très bien audio aux
échecs
alors on pourra lui faire faire partir
de la petite machine lui faire faire
plein de calculs pour atteindre l'état
de la grosse machine
mais bien sûr ce processus serait très
long et du coup jouer un coup des
chèques pour cette machine serait très
très très bref tout ça pour dire que le
raisonnement sur la complicité de
saumoneaux de la vidéo précédent il est
parfaitement juste d'un point de vue
théorique mais il a tendance à ignorer
le fait que certains calculs sont
nécessairement long et les intelligences
artificielles que l'on veut en pratique
sont des objets qui sont capables de
prendre des décisions rapidement du coup
si on prend en compte la théorie de la
complexité algorithmique en temps on se
rend compte que en fait il est quand
même possible pour des intelligences
artificielles de gagner en complexité de
solomonoff effective une fois qu'on a
pris en compte le temps de tout sans
avoir de données extérieures
ouais c'est un petit point un peu
technique que je trouve très très
fascinant et comme c'est un petit peu un
enfant de ce que j'ai dit en vidéo
précédente je pense je pense que ça vaut
le coup que je le signale à lescar qui
j'avais des jeux vidéo que vous allez
réfléchir à ce problème du où les
exclusifs jeu fait que ou exclusifs ne
peut pas être appris par la
qualification jr mais du coup comment
est ce qu'on peut faire pour vraiment
apprendre ou exclusif des pressions et
bien la prochaine fois c'est à cette
question qu'ont essayé de répondre si
j'avais mais cette vidéo pensez à la
ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour l'éternité et
futurs épisodes
merci au tibet repos leurs dons et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois mais il existe encore une autre
possibilité pour expliquer la
corrélation entre deux phénomènes a et b
il se peut que n'y a ni paix ne soit la
conséquence de l'autre mais bien qu'un
troisième phénomène appelons le
sobrement c'est soit la cause à la fois
2a et 2b de filosofia svr eastgate crown
system ligne classe praia da
maximiles distance reaching ces
pratiques populaires et des réponses